tonight is all about me
if i should go
yeah i think so
kristen wiig unexpectedly popped up
during will forte's snl hosting debut oh
god what does that say about me i don't
know it means you're a good friend
kristen even if will didn't seem
thrilled when you stopped by studio 8-h
as the comedian pointed out his big
night was a long time in the making i
was in the cast 12 years ago with
kristen wiig bill hader andy samberg
jason sedakis and fred armisen
so it was really fun to see kristen host
now then bill
you know
then andy
uh then fred
you know then kristen again
saved the best for last right
this led to forte's hilarious reaction
to the bridesmaids star's appearance
tonight is all about me
thank you
christian
hey
yeah
hey will i am so excited you're hosting
ah not a good time kristin joked her
surprise cameo wasn't easy to come by
okay yeah
what
well good to see you bye-bye
oh okay so yeah so i should go
yeah i think
so no i flew in for this
oh great so you know where the airport
is
all right well back to north korea
it was really hard to get out and if
that wasn't enough lauren michaels
revealed willem dafoe was supposed to be
hosting all right fine i'll take one
question you sir
i'm so sorry will there's been a mistake
hey
wait you you texted me to come host
lauren i texted willem and you know
autocorrect but jokes aside the
spider-man no way home star is hosting
next week with musical guest katy perry
i can't say anything will and kristin
also starred in a trio of mcgruber's
sketches alongside another famous face
ryan phillippe and the classic snl
character is more misguided than ever
now both of you hand me your mess
what what no time to explain mass now
mcgrubber what are you doing freeing us
from tyranny vic you're welcome
following the 2010 movie adaptation all
three actors just reprised their roles
in the magruber tv series on peacock i'm
in thank you soldier you're gonna get us
all killed speaking with e.t last month
will and kristen shared their excitement
for reuniting on screen we're just we're
very thankful to
to have this opportunity and we we just
you know we love
we
it's a little family that made the movie
that you know most everybody was back
together for the the tv series so we
just got really lucky yeah and i think
there's just something about there's so
many different types of
humor and i feel like this sort of falls
in that sort of silly
dumb
with all due respect
[Laughter]
dumb as a compliment
in the comedy world
[Music]
you